if
we look at our own brain which is an
interesting uh
illustrative example in your work with
testor
and trying to design uh deep learning
architectures
uh do you do you think about the brain
at all
maybe from a hardware designer
perspective
if you could uh change something about
the brain what would you change
or do for a funny question like how
would you so your brain is really weird
like you know your cereal cortex where
we think we do most of our thinking
is what like six or seven neurons thick
yeah like
that's weird like all the big networks
are way bigger than that
like way deeper so that seems odd and
then
you know when you're thinking if it's if
if the input
generates a result you can lose it goes
really fast but if it can't
that generates an output that's
interesting which turns into an input
and then your brain
to the point where you mold things over
for days and how many trips through your
brain is that right
like it's you know 300 milliseconds or
something to get through seven levels of
neurons
i forget the number exactly but then it
does it over and over and over as it
searches
and the brain clearly is looks like some
kind of graph because you have a neuron
with you know connections and it talks
to other ones and
it's locally very computationally
intense but it's also
does sparse computations across a pretty
big area
there's a lot of messy biological type
of things and it's
it's meaning like first of all there's
mechanical chemical and electrical
signals that's all that's going on
then the there's a the asynchronicity
of signals and there's like there's just
a lot of variability that seems
continuous and messy
and just a mess of biology and it's
unclear whether that's a
good thing yeah or it's a bad thing
because if
if it's a good thing that we need to run
the entirety of the evolution
well we're going to have to start with
basic bacteria to create something
imagining
we could control you could build a brain
with 10 layers would that be better or
worse
or more more connections or less
connections or you know
we don't know to what level our brains
are optimized
but if i was changing things like yeah
like you know you can only hold like
seven numbers in your head
yeah like why not 100 or a million never
thought of that like and why can't like
why can't we have like a floating point
processor that can compute anything we
want
like and see it all properly like that
would be kind of fun
and why can't we we see in four or eight
dimensions
like because you know 3d is kind of a
drag
like all the hard math transforms are up
in multiple dimensions
so there's that you know you could
imagine a brain architecture that
you know you could enhance with a whole
bunch of features that would be
you know really useful for thinking
about things it's possible that the
limitations you're describing are
actually
essential for like the constraints are
essential for creating
like the depth of intelligence like that
the ability to reason you know it's hard
to say because
like your brain is clearly a parallel
processor
you know you know 10 billion neurons
talking to each other at a relatively
low clock rate
but it produces something that looks
like a serial thought process
it's a serial narrative in your head
that's true right but then
there are people famously who are visual
thinkers like
i think i'm a relatively visual thinker
i can
imagine any object and rotate it in my
head and look at it
and there are people who say they don't
think that way at all
and recently i read an article about
people people who say they don't have a
they don't have a voice in their head
they they
can talk but when they you know it's
like well what are you thinking
they'll they'll describe something
that's visual
so that's curious
now if if you're saying
if we dedicated more hardware to holding
information like you know
10 numbers or a million numbers like
would that
just distract us from our ability to
form this kind of
singular identity like it dissipates
somehow right
but but maybe you know future humans
will have many identities that
have some higher level organization but
can actually do lots more things in
parallel
yeah there's no reason if we're thinking
modularly there's no reason we can't
have multiple consciousnesses
in one brain yeah and maybe there's some
way to make it faster so that the
you know the area the computation could
could still have a unified feel to it
but
while still having way more ability to
do parallel stuff at the same time
could definitely be improved could be
improved yeah okay
well it's it's pretty good right now
actually people don't give it enough
credit the thing is pretty nice
you